Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan.
Es ist Salon, Zeit. Der Juli ist rum. Wir lesen ja immer so ein paar Tage in den Monat hinein, die Sachen vom letzten Monat. Heute sind bei mir, glaube ich, Texte reingerutscht. Die sind eigentlich schon August, aber egal. Du verlässt wieder das Haus nicht nur für den Salon, sondern auch für Museen, möchtest du uns sagen?
Ja, genau. Ich war noch mal in Frankfurt. Wir waren ja schon letzte Woche zusammen Schnitzel essen und podcasten und ich musste für einen kleinen Dreh für so eine MDR-Mediatheke nach Frankfurt und dachte mir, dann nutze ich doch die Zeit und gehe mal endlich wieder ins Museum. Und es ist, glaube ich, anderthalb Jahre her, dass ich in der Schirn war und das ist eine Kunsthalle, die ich ja sehr schätze und die tolle Ausstellungen machen. Und da waren zwei Ausstellungen, einmal Gilbert & George. Da muss ich sagen, das hat mich nicht so begeistert. Das habe ich mir aber auch eigentlich schon gedacht. Das ist so ein berühmtes Künstlerpaar, die sehr provokante Sachen in den 70ern gemacht haben, auch in den 80ern. Aber wenn man sich das heute ansieht, diese Art der Pop Art und auch diese starke Arbeit mit Text, dann ist das doch etwas, was man heute schon so viel gesehen hat im Internet. Ich glaube, auch durch diese Meme Kultur wirft diese Kunst gar nicht mehr so und hat dann doch etwas sehr Museales plötzlich dann wirklich im Museum, dass man sagt, ach ja, so war das damals. Und die sind natürlich immer noch künstlerisch tätig. Aber das hat natürlich keinen wirklichen Stachel mehr. Und dann bin ich dort auch nicht so lange geblieben und bin lieber in die andere Ausstellung in der Schirn gegangen. Und die trägt den Titel Magnetic North. Und das ist eine Ausstellung, die vom Norden handelt, aber vom Norden in Amerika, nämlich von Kanada und handelt von Malern, die Anfang des 20. Jahrhunderts aus einem Eskapismus heraus, aus einer Naturliebe heraus, aber auch einer gewissen Skepsis gegenüber der modernen Welt heraus sagen, wir müssen jetzt in die Landschaft, wir müssen hinaus, wir müssen die Wälder malen, die unberührten Landschaften malen. Und da sind ganz großartige Landschafts- gemälde und auch Skizzen entstanden. Und das war sehr beeindruckend, denn bei mir ist es ja so, im Gegensatz zu dir, gehe ich ja nicht so gern in die Natur, aber ich liebe Landschafts- gemälde und das konnte ich dort sehr genießen. Und das Tolle ist auch, dass die Ausstellung den Kolonialismus auch verhandelt, denn wenn da immer gesagt wird, das ist die unberührte Natur, dann ist das selbstverständlich ein sehr weißer Blick auf die Geschichte Kanadas, denn so unberührt war die nicht. Da waren ja Menschen und was ist mit denen geschehen? Das ist etwas, was die Ausstellung thematisiert, was die Künstler meist ausgeblendet haben, außer eine Künstlerin, die das auch immer wieder zum Thema machte. Es sind ja sehr, sehr schöne große Bilder da, aber auch kleine Skizzen, die eigentlich mich noch mehr fasziniert haben. Und man kennt wenig von kanadischer Kunst. Und man sieht aber trotzdem natürlich Parallelen zu europäischer Kunst, zum Impressionismus, zum Expressionismus. Aber es ist doch was sehr eigenständiges dann, was in diesen Landschaften entstanden ist. Und irgendwann in einem Raum geht es dann auch um die Industrialisierung. Und dann malen sie diese Fabriken, wie die in die Landschaften gestellt werden, die Sägewerke und all das. Und das sind sehr deprimierende Bilder. Denn wenngleich wir natürlich genau von dieser Industrialisierung profitieren, denn wir wollen ja nicht in die Höhlen zurück. Also eine Ausstellung, die doch sehr mich begeistert hat.
Du bist also ein Natur-Banause. Dann lass mich noch fragen, welche Ausstellung ist oben? Ich nehme mal an, die Kanada-Ausstellung ist dann nicht oben unterm Dach, ne?
Es sind, oh jetzt muss ich gerade überlegen, wie geht man denn da? Denn es gibt eine extra Corona-Strecke, die auch dann noch nach außen führt. Ich glaube, die Ausstellung ist, nee, die ist auch ziemlich weit oben. Ja, also ich glaube, die haben das ein bisschen umgebaut.
Schöne, große Raum unterm Dach, wo auch so ein bisschen Natur liegt, aber nicht so viel Natur. Du siehst nicht den Himmel, es ist immer hell.
Also diese ganz großen Räume, die sind für Gilbert und George vorbereitet, denn das sind so großformatige Werke, da braucht man einfach den Platz, sonst geht das gar nicht.
Ja, sehr gut. Ich könnte ja mit dem Fahrrad hinfahren. Ich würde eigentlich zu Fuß hinlaufen. Ich habe ja hier alle Museen, die irgendwie von Rang und Namen sind auf der Welt, hier vor Ort. Also ein bisschen übertrieben, aber. Und ich krübel immer noch, gehe ich jetzt zuerst in die Schirn oder ins Städel, denn ich war auch lange nicht im Museum. Und bei der Schirn muss man sich immer drauf einlassen. Was zeigen sie gerade? Beckmann. Wem ist man gerade ausgeliefert sozusagen? Welchen Kurator? Während man im Städel eben weiß, Ach so, im Städel. In Goethe, in Goethe im Treppenhaus, da geht man einfach durch. Alte Meister, Neue Meister, dann noch so ein bisschen was.
Ja, also Städel zeigt Beckmann, also die haben eine Sonderausstellung, aber sonst kannst du natürlich alles andere ja auch sehen. Also die ständige Sammlung, die gibt es in der Schirn nicht. Was ein bisschen schade war, ich hätte mir gerne einen Katalog gekauft, aber das war auf so schlechtem Papier gedruckt, dass die Farben dieser Gemälde überhaupt nicht mehr wiedergegeben wurden. Das war alles so blass, dass man auch sich fragt, warum spart man da jetzt ein paar Euro Papier?
Vielleicht hat da jemand an die Natur gedacht und hat Recycle-Papier benutzt. Ja, wer weiß, wer weiß.
Das ist natürlich die Sache, aber ich würde sagen, Natur ist erst dann interessant, wenn sie künstlerisch bearbeitet wird.
Was ich dir noch empfehlen kann, wenn du eh schon in der Schirn bist, also für alle, die dir jetzt folgen, auch in die Schirn zu gehen, direkt daneben ist ja unser neues Stadt- oder Dingsmuseum, also Drehung mit Amrömer. Und da habe ich nur gehört, deswegen bin ich auch schon ein bisschen hibbelig und will da mit meinen Kindern bei nächster Gelegenheit mal hin, ist wohl oben unterm Dach Frankfurt nachgebaut, aber nun aus Alltagsgegenständen, die man eigentlich in den Müll schmeißt. Und man muss aber ganz genau hinschauen, habe ich gehört, um zu sehen, stimmt, das ist ja eine Zigaretten Schachtel oder das ist ja eine Streichholz Schachtel oder das ist ja eine Bierdose oder wie auch immer, dass es so ein bisschen verschleiert ist, woraus es gemacht ist. Ja, also da habe ich bisher nur Gutes von gehört und deswegen bin ich da erpicht, darauf mir das dann mal anzuschauen.
Es ist schön wieder mal rauszugehen und auch so ein paar flüchtige Begegnungen zu haben. Zum Beispiel war da eine Dame, die Aufpasserin ist im Museum und mich dann ansprach und sagte, sie haben aber einen tollen Anzug und dann wissen wollte, was sie denn herhaben.
Das ist Frankfurter Klasse, weißt du?
Ja, das ist Frankfurter Klasse und die mir auch dann noch nachrief, als ich ging, behalten sie sich ihre Linie. Also auch nochmal eine kleine Ermahnung. Das fand ich wirklich herrlich.
Sehr gut, ja so sind wir hier in Frankfurt. Ich kann leider nichts berichten. Ich bin in Urlaubsvorfreude. Ich packe meine Sachen und werde noch diese Tage abfahren an die Küste. Natur pur, sag ich nur. Also nichts, was jeder in der Welt macht.
Sehr klimafreundlich. Also du wirst nicht in Flugzeuge steigen.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Wir fahren ja mit dem Auto, aber dem Auto sitzen fünf Menschen. Also eine sehr gute Quote pro Person. Und einmal angekommen bleibt dieses Auto auch stehen, wird nicht mal mehr angeschaut für 14 Tage. Ich fahre mit dem Lastenrad und alles ist gut. Und danach danach werde ich mich auch wieder der Kultur hier zuwenden in Frankfurt, denn es ist wirklich crazy, wenn man sich das so anschaut, was man alles liegen lässt. Und jetzt so langsam kommen ja auch diese Texte. Erwachen aus Corona, aber eben nur so halb und irgendwelche Tanzschulen und so weiter haben sich anderthalb Jahre durchgeschlagen und stellen jetzt fest, wir schaffen es nicht noch mal ein Jahr so auf halbe Flamme irgendwie zu fahren und so. Und treffen jetzt die Entscheidung. Jetzt ergeben sich auch wieder andere Möglichkeiten. Lassen wir mal unser Leben zurück. Und ich bin sehr erpicht darauf. Und deswegen hier der Aufruf auch an alle, die es hören. Mich interessiert im August, wenn wir Neue Zwanziger im August machen, die Frage, wie konnte es passieren, dass wir die Vermieter so sorglos durch diese Corona Pandemie haben segeln lassen? In Deutschland ist es wichtiger, dass ein Vermieter pünktlich seine Miete bekommt. Dafür lässt man gerne mal 500 Schüler einer Tanzschule über die Klippe springen und sagen, Tori tut uns leid, diese Tanzschule gibt es nicht mehr. Wir mussten dem Vermieter pünktlich die Miete zahlen. Und das interessiert mich jetzt auf allen Ebenen. Denn das läuft immer so nebenher als wirklich latentes, schreiendes Problem, ohne mal ausgesprochen zu werden, wenn man so auf tagesschau.de die Listen an irgendwelchen Besuchen vor Ort, wo mal wieder die Läden nicht wieder aufmachen, wo es nicht geklappt hat und die Orientierungslosigkeit und die spontane Armut plötzlich reingeschlagen hat. Und nicht ein Wort wird zu diesen Vermietern gesagt. Das ist wirklich unglaublich. Also ja, Marcel Fratsch hat das mal in einem seiner Podcasts da angemerkt. Fand ich auch sehr gut. Clips habe ich natürlich. Aber ansonsten dieses, also wie die Vermieter durch die Pandemie gesegelt sind, da interessiert mich alles, was euch dazu einfällt.
Sehr gut. Das muss ein Thema werden. Ja, das ist ein großes Thema und das ist auch erstaunlich. Ich war jetzt bei 13 Fragen zu Gast und da war dann auch so ein, jemand vom Familienunternehmerverband oder so, der dann auch sagte, nein, das sind ja auch Unternehmen. Also wenn man Wohnungen vermietet, dann ist man ja auch ein Unternehmer, dann tut man ja etwas für die Gesellschaft und man fragt sich dann ja, wo denn gerade?
Ja, was denn?
Es ist ja auch immer diese interessante Illusion, dass gesagt wird, ja, wir brauchen Anreize, dass viel gebaut wird, denn die wollen ja gar keine Knappheit haben und das stimmt halt nicht. Also man kann ja Mieten nur wirklich lukrativ einnehmen, wenn eine Knappheit vorherrscht. Wenn es jetzt Wohnungen ohne Ende in Frankfurt gäbe, wäre ich ja ein Idiot, wenn ich auch noch eine bauen würde.
Ja, und am Ende sind das, also wenn dann wirklich mal achtstöckig gebaut wird, dann steckt die Stadt dahinter. Wenn du den Leuten das selber bauen lässt, nee, das muss hier schön umgehbar sein. Ich brauche einen Garten, der muss riesig sein. Weißt du, das ist alles unausgegoren und das gehört mal thematisiert. Und ja, ich habe die Sendung auch gesehen. Das Spielkonzept finde ich so ein bisschen, na gut, man steht halt da und muss so einen Schritt vor oder zurück gehen.
Wir haben es aber torpediert. Also wir haben es ja, wir haben uns nicht bewegt.
Es gab keinen Kommiss. Einfach Mikado, genau. Niemand bewegt sich. Und ja, dass dann irgendwann noch zwischendurch noch mal so ein Typ rein ruft. Aber wer investiert denn dann, wenn nicht die Leute, die die Miete? Also als ob irgendein Vermieter in Deutschland das Geld investiert in irgendwas. Das sind doch abenteuerliche Vorstellungen.
Vielleicht dann in Aktien oder Bitcoin. Aber vielleicht müssen wir das, Stefan, auf nationalstaatlicher Ebene ja lösen. Und damit leite ich über zu unserem großen Buch, das wir besprechen. 500 Seiten, Wolfgang Streeck zwischen Globalismus und Demokratie. Also hier wird schon eine Opposition aufgemacht. Entweder man will Global Governance, man will diese globale Ordnung, man will EU oder welche Institution auch immer. Oder Demokratie. Also diese Opposition wird sehr stark gemacht in dem Buch. Und man muss ja auch noch hinzufügen, dass Wolfgang Streeck immer mal wieder wohl Sarah Wagenknecht berät. Ich würde aber gleich schon mal die These in den Raum stellen. Ja, das mag ja sein. Aber dann hat Wagenknecht Streeck nicht gründlich konsultiert oder nicht gründlich gelesen. Denn da sind ja doch einige Dinge dann zum Klimawandel am Ende drin, die einen enorm überraschen werden. Wenngleich dieses Buch auch einige Schwierigkeiten mit sich bringt, die du, glaube ich, mehr nachempfunden hast als ich.
Ja, ich hatte vor allen Schwierigkeiten mit dem Buch, weil es hat mich dann auch irgendwann gelangweilt und ich dachte mir irgendwann, er stellt ja am Anfang, um das schon mal zu sagen, seine Lektoren als Kampfsportlerin gegen ihn vor. Und als ich dann mal geschaut habe, wie viele Seiten das Buch eigentlich hat, weil ich lese sowas ja nicht so wie du. Also ich habe es ja nicht in der Hand. Ich habe ja nicht so ein Manifest, so ein Block irgendwie in der Hand. Habe ich gedacht, oh Gott, also das hätte man ja nun wirklich mal kampfsportlerisch ordentlich runterdreschen können, aber wurde nicht getan. Deswegen war es sehr lang. Allerdings, ich habe noch ein längeres Buch im Angebot und das ist einfach ein Spektakel. Also ich will es hier schon mal ausdrücklich sagen, auch für alle Nicht-Salon-Abonnenten, wenn ihr noch mal ein richtig geiles Buch über Trump lesen wollt, I Alone Can Fix It von Carol Leoning oder wie auch immer und Philip Rooker, also den beiden WAPO-Typen, die auch schon A Very Stable Genius geschrieben haben und dieses letzte Jahr von Donald Trump, da ging es drunter und drüber. Wir besprechen ja allerdings nur die Aspekte zu Mark Milley. Das alleine sprengt schon jede Imagination eines guten Drehbuchs. Also hier hat die Realität wirklich alles aus den Angeln gehoben. Es ist unfassbar. Also da freue ich mich dann sehr drauf, wenn wir Streeck durchhaben, über dieses Buch zu sprechen.
Na ja, jetzt sagt es nicht so durchhaben. Es ist ja doch erstaunlich, was er so alles nochmal herausarbeitet. Also was uns beiden wahrscheinlich gefallen wird, ist, dass er auch nochmal gegen Menasse und Giro schießt. Das macht er auch sehr korrekt. Was dann verwunderlich ist, oder nicht verwunderlich in seine These, aber doch, wie er da, wie hart er Adam Twos angreift. Wenngleich er da auch nicht ungerecht vorgeht. Also er macht das aus seinem Blickwinkel heraus. Er hat eigentlich so eine anfängliche Polemik drin, aber es wird dann nachher weniger und es wird doch... Also es gibt noch mal so einen tollen Twist, finde ich, den er uns bietet, nachdem wir durch viel, ja, Systemtheorie, Überlegungen und sonst was schreiben mussten.
Also ein Buch zu lesen, klar, ich rede nicht über alle Bücher. Es gibt Bücher, die sind Verschwendung, aber Bücher aus der Kategorie deutscher Professor schreibt noch mal am Ende, was er denkt über alle Sachen. So Wolfgang Streeck halt, ne? Die kann man, wenn man sie nicht informativ liest, immer noch inspirativ lesen. Und er hat ja genug Masse, an der man sich abarbeiten kann. Manche Bücher sind dann halt so ein Wetzstein, an der man seine Klinge noch mal schärft. Und das ist bei ihm insbesondere so, da er immer wieder von der Systemtheorie redet. Und ich mich frage, was meinst du denn damit? Das ist jedenfalls nicht meine Systemtheorie. Also da lässt er so ein paar Sachen liegen, die allerdings dann in der Interpretation, also wenn man darüber spricht, kann man sie noch mal deutlich machen. Aber es ist eben anders gelagert, als wenn man jetzt so ein Move-Buch hat, wie beim letzten Mal oder so, wo wirklich noch mal Sachen drinsteht, die man vorher nicht wusste.
Aber man kann es ganz gut aus Parallel nochmal mit Move in Verbindung bringen. Alles stimmt. Und dann wird auch noch mal einiges klarer oder auch unklarer. Also ich finde, es wirbelt einen auch ein bisschen auf, gerade diese Bücher so hintereinander gelesen zu haben. Bei mir geht es aber nicht nur um die globalen Fragen, sondern auch mal ums Kleine vor der Haustür oder im Laden. Wie verändert sich da eigentlich Design? Da habe ich einen ganz interessanten Aufsatz. Dann geht es nochmal um Tiktok. Da hat man doch einiges jetzt herausgefunden über den Algorithmus, wie er funktioniert. Dann nochmal Schulden, warum die nicht schlimm sind. Das wissen wir schon. Da haben wir auch schon einige Argumente gebracht. Es gibt aber nochmal ein paar neue Argumente, die ich für wichtig erachte. Dann haben wir es mit Migration global zu tun, mit Flucht global zu tun. Und natürlich gibt es auch Leute, die aus Indien fliehen. Und zwar fliehen die jetzt immer lieber mal in die USA, wenn sie denn können. Und ich hatte das letzte Mal schon angekündigt, diesmal aber dann wirklich. Es wird um den Roman Der Untertan gehen von Heinrich Mann. Jetzt sagst du, müssen wir denn jetzt hier Literatur von 1916 lesen? Und ich werde dir sagen, ja.
Okay, ich bin gespannt. Ich sag nur noch kurz, Friederike Haupt hat über Angela Merkel und den Gender Aspekt in ihrer finalen politischen, wie soll man sagen, Wallung geschrieben. Edward Snowden hat sich zu Wort gemeldet durch den Pegasus-Skandal. Das ist natürlich sein Thema. Noch mal fünf Punkte über, wir leben in ganz unsicheren Zeiten. Und ein wirklicher Spektakeltext. Johannes Schneider hat in der Zeit über den heiligen Rentner geschrieben. Und zwar nicht die echten Rentner, die es gibt und die zur Hälfte in Armut leben und so weiter, sondern die Rentner, wie sie die Politik sich vorstellt, wenn sie uns erklären will, was zukünftig möglich ist oder nicht. Und das ist auch ästhetisch. Und ich sage ausdrücklich ästhetisch und nicht nur herzig mühe geben beim Schreiben, sondern es ist einfach ein Spektakel. Also in deren Sicht, leider ist der Text jetzt hinter die Paywall gewandert. Im Sinne von, die Zeit verdient gut daran, hoffe ich. Solche Texte müssen dann auch bezahlt werden, das finde ich gut. Ich habe ihn zum Glück noch vor der Paywall gelesen. Sonst hätte ich ihn mir gekauft, aber das ist echt gut. Gut, soweit. Dann können wir ja in den Salon stürmen.
Ja, bis gleich.
Bis gleich.